hello i'm omar and along with jonathan
i'll be
presenting our sort of novel crispr
enzyme discovery work and engineering
for both diagnostics
and transcriptome engineering so
to get started you know a lot of our
work
uh sort of looks at harnessing natural
diversity
to find new enzymes and things that
bacteria or other organisms
have developed that we can apply to new
tools and
there's a really big precedence for this
from research enzymes for muscular
cloning to
uh sort of crispr for gene editing as
well as viral vectors and a lot of other
technologies and so um in our work
when we were starting out uh many years
ago uh within the christopher
uh realm uh cast nine was kind of the
biggest
uh sort of single effector tool that
people uh
were looking at there was only a small
slice of
sort of diversity of crystal enzymes and
we
wanted to ask questions of whether there
was a way to expand
uh this diversity and so
uh to do that we looked at signatures of
common crispr systems and one of the
main signatures
is this uh presence of cast one and cast
two which are the
uh proteins responsible for crispr
memory um and of course you could also
use crispr arrays or other sort of
highly conserved features of crispr
systems
um but we focused on it on cast one and
cast two uh we built a computational
pipeline with collaborators
uh such as eugene kunin uh to look for
new systems and we could use this cast
one to blast many
contigs uh across you know hundreds of
thousands of bacterial genomes you find
new proteins that are nearby cast one
you can cluster them and build out new
candidate systems
now we found many different types of
systems when we did this
including cpf1 which is the type 5as
here
which are dna targeting and we also
could find uh sort of
rna targeting systems as well which is
the c2c2
uh type six system which is very
interesting to us because it looks very
different than other known
single effector crispr systems because
of its rna domains
did a lot of work to characterize the
system as a programmable rna targeting
system which
could actually be used to defend against
rna phages or
dna phages when they express their
transcripts and those can be targeted
and we showed that it generated many
cuts in the uh
rna genome it could even degrade the
rnas with time
now one of the really interesting
features of this system is
not only would it degrade the target
it's bound to but we also degrade any
other rnas in solution so once the
protein bound it would have a lot of
promiscuous activity and other rnas
we could actually interestingly leverage
that for
actual technology purposes so
if you make a cleavage reporter that has
a fluorophore quencher on each end
these dumbbell shaped reporters can
actually be cleaved by the collateral
activity
upon the presence of a target rna and so
uh we we tried this out and uh we
actually could get fluorescent detection
with this approach
uh but it wasn't super sensitive so
detection was down to maybe you know
millions of molecules per microliter so
you know sort of high femtomolar uh low
picomolar range
um and so we thought of ways to make
this really sensitive
uh for your actual clinical applications
where you might want to detect one to
ten copies of something per microliter
so we developed this uh tool which we
ended up naming sherlock and
had to engineer what the acronym would
actually be for that
uh but basically it could take dna or
rna
um and you feed it into a
preamplification reaction such as rpa
shown here and that could amplify a lot
more dna uh
along with transcription handles which
allow us to make it into rna
which can then be detected by the crispr
systems
and all this can happen in one reaction
which is really nice
so casper team detection is shown here
where you really don't get detection
below uh sort of the
peak molar high pentamole range but with
sherlock and amplification
uh we actually could get down to single
molecule level detection or low atom or
um and same with dna so both rna and dna
worked well here
and we're pretty excited about all the
places we can take certain crispr
diagnostics um
you know of course for uh infectious
disease as well as point of care and at
home detection
and genotyping as well and i think this
is really irrelevant uh in today's time
uh
where we're all you know maybe working
from home and uh
trying to make it through a pandemic uh
i think
you know early on back in january uh we
sort of
teamed up along with fungus group to
make sherlock even better
and make his protection even better to
make it more relevant for at home or
point of care copic detection
and the way we did that is we wanted to
really make the one step sherlock that
all where all the pieces work in one
tube a lot better
and faster um so we're actually able to
engineer hotter
cas12 enzymes uh that work in a in
concert with a lamp instead of rpa
and we can run the whole reaction at 60
degrees and some of these hotter cast 12
enzymes you know they have to be able to
work in the 60 degree range and we're
able to find them from bacteria that
actually grow
in like rotten fruit juice and so
this new master mix is really great
because then you can take a swab or
saliva
um basically do a quick extraction add
it to this reaction
and then just do a 60 minute incubation
if you want lateral flow detection or
we've gotten 20 to 30 minute detection
if you real-time fluorescence on like a
simple portable device um
and that's been really exciting and the
lateral flow detection has actually been
very good on
a wide range of clinical samples with
low end high viral loads shown here
we can get about 97 detection the top
line indicates detection so most deposit
samples have detection and
the five negative samples do not and
that corresponds to about 97 sensitivity
um 100 specificity when you look across
your whole data set
and uh and that's you know kind of
uh we're really excited about for
christopher diagnostics is really moving
that forward you know we have this
really
great optimized master mix now which we
call stop uh
stands for sherlock testing on one pot
and we're kind of excited
where we can maybe take this maybe on a
simple device is kind of what we're
thinking these days about
uh you know having all in one sort of
system that can run this chemistry and
be deployed in any setting
um so hopefully we'll have more on that
in the future uh
now cas13 also interestingly is not just
useful for diagnostics um
there's a lot of cellular applications
that we can start to think about and rna
of course is involved in so many
different processes in the cell so
having tools
to nuclear rna is important um
and you know two things you can do with
our program one of the returning tools
of the many things you could do is
already knock down the base editing
um we've talked a lot about in the past
four are they knocked down but i think
the base editing stuff is more
uh interesting and more recent so i'll
dive into that a bit
um but basically you know a big question
is why aren't they editing when dna
is so great well you know there's a lot
of applications that
uh could benefit from temporal
modulation um you know modulating
protein function if you want to turn
something that's active inactive or
inactive too active an example of that
is turning on like hepatocytes or heart
cells and
cases of you know liver failure or heart
failure
um or you know even just modulating the
immune system or modulating pain
um correction mendelian diseases can
also be done
um which is useful um as well as
splicing modulation and
it's really useful for mutations that
you want to correct that you're not sure
if you want permanent correction or
also don't want to worry about permanent
off targets as well
um so there's a lot of applications for
rna editing
um and i think it's really cool that
uh how how we can take advantage
actually of the
of uh natural processes so we basically
can make an rna ending tool by of sort
of recruiting natural enzymes that are
occurring in the cells such as adida
enzymes just from
adenosine to innocent and so um i think
that's a pretty good intro and i'll
pass it on to jonathan now um who can
actually sort of talk about our work in
the space
and uh you know what we've been doing uh
with programmable rna editing tools
great thanks so much for that great
introduction so
share my screen here
so as elmore mentioned rna editing
essentially can be
done by a suite of enzymes in the cell
most notably one of them is
adar or adenosine diaminas actin and rna
and
we can actually engineer rna editing by
using
the adrdg the d amino domain we can fuse
it with the
catalytically activated cas13b and we
can pair that with a
guide rna with a specific mismatch in it
so this mismatch can signify the target
adenosine
with a mismatched cytosine here then we
can actually target it to a specific
adenosine
and the 8rd avenue domain will convert
that to an interesting
so we call this repair or rna editing
for programmable 8i replacement
and here's an example of repair so this
is on
a reporter transcript cripperidino
luciferase where we have a
pre-termination construct here um
this uh tryptophan we've converted to a
stop codon
so by putting this uh different base
here this
setting opposite of it we can actually
evoke rna editing
and this is a tiling of guides across it
you can see that
this uh specifically edited uh
target can be quite efficiently edited
by a number of guides
and ending rates um up to 25
so one thing that we wanted to make sure
was that we had
a great specificity of this tool so if
we
do genome-wide or state
transcription-wide sequencing and look
for
rna editing events compared to um
without the
chemistry you can see that our
cooperating
actually we can get by this readout up
to 90
editing but we have off targets across
the transcriptome so
we thought to ourselves how can we
actually do rational improvement of the
technology
to prevent editing across at these
unexpected and on
desired sites so what we did is we took
uh rational design via structural
information so this is a
schematic from peter beale's lab where
essentially we can identify interacting
residues of the adodes domain and then
we can
mutagenize them so they both
retain activity so this is the on target
score but have
increased specificity as well so we want
something with a high on target and
specificity score
so we use this to develop a repair v2
construct
that is much more specific across the
transcriptome so here's that
uh manhattan plot of repair v1 before
and then here you can see with repair v2
we essentially have an elimination of
all of these off-target editing sites
across the transcriptome here's
uh just a zoom in at the actual select
site so
we have essentially the
um editing here at this desired
adenosine and you can see converge
g's via innocence but there's all these
off targets
then when we actually introduce these
mutations
we only have our pure product so
this can also be applied to a number of
sites so we can do editing on
targets such as kras and you can see
here we have um
above 30 editing with repair v1 and
we take a small small decrease with
repair v2 but that
allows us to not have off target edit
editing across the other sites
um in kras so this is great
but we thought that how can we engineer
the enzyme in the system to be even
more powerful so one thing of course is
that
adai editing allows you to make a
certain set of
restorative or inner function mutations
as omar mentioned
but what would be really fantastic would
be a system that allows us to
have uh editing of additional
conversions so this is cdu editing
with a lot of things like conversion of
phosphorylated residues
to non-phosphorylated residues so this
begs the question
how do we do cdu editing
so expanding the targeting range of our
netting was a big interest of ours
so we thought maybe we can actually
perform directed evolution
of these ar domains and with that's
based upon a predicate of
if you see how the adar domains interact
with the
uh pocket you can actually see in when
there's an
adenosine bound the corresponding
situating gaminases
interact quite well but the if you put a
setting analog in
gives you only a couple of residues
actually block the deamination there
so what we did is we did a direct
evolution of adar
to actually generate a cdu editor so
we took a campaign of rational
mutagenesis
much like with repair v2 to nominate
some residues
and then put that into a direct
evolution pipeline where we could
use yeast expression of the ar
on an oxytrophic mutant to restore
activity and then
we can select mutants there that are
valid
in mammalian cells and then iterate that
process
so this allows us to make a pipeline of
different versions around the selection
so this cdu editor we call um
a setting urine editor or rescue um
and it is actually quite uh an efficient
process so
here is another luciferase based
reporter now it's gaussian phrase but
it's a similar concept where we're
restoring a mutation
and these mobile rounds of editing
actually took us from essentially
undetectable levels of editing up to 70
editing at this transcript site
here's a different site so we do have
some variation where we're only getting
four percent editing due to
a undesirable motif but you can see
still that we get
strong amounts of editing and this is
dependent on the fusion so
other rna targeting technologies can um
try to avoid recruitment for your crispr
but we tested those with our mutant
the adrd mutation and if you just
introduce that alone
or as mutations on the full-length
protein they're still not effective
at cdu editing so this shows that
perhaps we co-evolved it with the cast
13 to fold it or something
but what we do find is that it's very
effective
and we can also target a panel of
endogenous genes and
see quite effective editing up to and
above 30
on some targets um and we
have confidence that it is transferable
to a large number of genes with many
different phenotypic outputs
for example beta-catenine so
the beta-categorian pathway is involved
in wind singling so
phosphorylation of beta-catenin
leads to its degradation in the absence
of wind signaling in the presence of
wind singling
lack of phosphorylation leads to
stabilization and translocation to the
nucleus
so what we thought was that perhaps
these
domains that are either directly
phosphorylated or involved in
phosphorylation
we can apply the rescue approach to edit
them
and then prevent phosphorylation and
these phosphorylation
then dead uh beta-catenin uh variants
will then
be able to signal and do things like
increased growth and this is very
interesting because
when the wind pathway is a very relevant
uh pharmaceutical target
but it's also something that you need to
have very strong control over
so using these pathways and these
targets is
very easy because for example if you
deliver the rescue
chemistry transiently it will be diluted
out so what we did is we actually
tested guides against beta kitchen
finding guys that could do
up to about thirty percent editing and
using beta containing activity reporters
or
tcf reporters we can actually see that
this
leads to a strong up regulation of the
pathway
this leads to cell growth so here this
is an assay where we actually take a
plug out of the
cells and they grow in and you can see
in the absence of this
they grow in slightly but the presence
they grow in actually quite
substantially and
to quantify that you can see we have
significant more growth in these
situations
so this is only one of the many
applications of the rescue platform and
rna
in general where we can obviously
correct mendelian diseases or multiplex
to correct them
using the multiplexing capabilities of
cat 13
we can also modulate the catalysis or
post-translational states of
proteins and do this in a transient
fashion so this allows us to have
the precision of genome editing with
the uh kinetics and permanence of more
similar to other biologics or even small
molecules
so we only scratch the surface of what
these rna binding proteins can do
such as cast 13 inside the mammalian
cells so of course we can modulate
translation
or splicing or localization even
transcriptomics have been recent papers
using cast 13 for changing the m6a
states for example
and we see this toolbox is a rapidly
growing uh capability
maybe not as strong or as uh
full as the cast nine or dna targeting
toolbox but the only tool targeting
toolbox
is certainly getting there so to take it
back one
step to where we started yes natural
diversity
has been a risk resource resource of
course of crispr enzymes but also
other enzymes such as deaminases or
other genome modifying enzymes such as
integrases or recombinases so we're very
excited about using these and minding
these in a
comprehensive manner to find new tools
for
genome editing and translational
applications
so as omar mentioned
we're co-writing a lab together at the
montgomery institute now
um and we're excited about exploring
into
uh that natural diversity we'd also like
to thank everybody who was involved with
this
much of this work was done in zhang's
lab while we were graduate students
especially with david cox as well as
many other people who contributed
we're co-founders of sherlock
biosciences and advisor for beam
and you can check out our research at
hubbagoot.mnt.edu thanks for listening
and we're happy to take any questions
thanks so much
you